patrick mennucci un commentaire sur time
peut-être non je je je je n'attendais
pas moins c'est la marque d'une
municipalité qui a bien fait son travail
qui a intégré la question écologique et
dieu sait si anne hidalgo a été attaqué
sur cet aspect des choses
voilà je crois que c'est tout à fait
satisfaisant
nous nous y attendions et ça fait partie
des grandes victoires le parti
socialiste et la gauche ce soir beaucoup
de victoires montpellier est en train de
tomber et je n'ai lu michaël delafosse
naître le maire voilà il ya beaucoup de
villes moyennes aussi je crois que la
gauche peut être satisfaite ce soit bon
à paris votre réaction patrick mennucci
sûr c'est un ministère et de ses
ministres à ce scrutin des municipales
en août et je crois que ce qui me paraît
important c'est dans une élection il
vraiment ce qu'on regarde ville par
ville mais il me semble que ce soir
c'est pas la victoire d'edouard philippe
au havre qui peut cacher la débandade de
la république en marche dans cette
élection et je note d'ailleurs que les
mères qui ont vu dans le passé être
socialiste et qui ont rejoint la
république en marche sont battus ce soit
je pense à lorient et je pense surtout à
montpellier où michael delafosse
d'avancé confirmé a fait basculer la
ville qui revient la ville de georges
frêche qui revient au parti socialiste
dont kylie a aujourd'hui plus de 60
villes nouvelles qui vont être dirigée
par un maire socialiste alors je sais
qu'on va dire que il y a
la victoire des bucks philippe mais en
aucun cas elle ne peut masquer les
analyses qui seront faites sur le fait
que le parti guéiste retrouve beaucoup
de communes et gagne et regagner des
communes qu'il avait perdue par exemple
à périgueux ou à tyrosse des villes
moyennes grandes sur tout le territoire
c'est je crois très important pour la
gauche mennucci donc vous des clairement
que cette élection est un vote sanction
pour la république en marche et un petit
peu de vigueur retrouvée pour le parti
socialiste qui en manquait grandement je
vais pas dire que c'est
c'était une sanction pour la république
en moi je pense que ce serait pas la
vérité la république est en marche à
tous et je dirais pour ne pas être au
fond prises au sérieux par les électeurs
et présente les candidats qu'ils ont
présentés n'étaient pas prêts ils ont
polémiqué entre parfois il ya eu des
listes dissidentes
non je crois que il faut distinguer les
choses il y a
dans l'ignoble la crise sanitaire la
crise sanitaire a eu un impact selon
vous la gestion ne compte pas je ne sais
pas il faudra avoir le résultat de de
toulouse peut-être mais regardez à
bourges où le maire a fait des
distributions de masque pendant trois
mois ils viennent d'être battus par
l'ancien député socialiste et yann galut
donc moi ce qui me semble surtout c'est
que le parti socialiste est un parti de
formation un parti qui construit
localement territorialement de bonne
politique et cesser bonne politique
ce soir qui sont qui ont été mises en
avant par les électeurs quand les
électeurs nous ont donné la majorité
dans autant de villes et je crois pas
qu'il faille à tirer des conséquences de
sanctions il faut simplement remarquer
que la république manche n'est pas un
parti politique il y a une personnalité
emmanuel matrones qui effectivement une
personnalité qui compte beaucoup au
premier rang dans ce pays mais il n'a
pas derrière lui une organisation qui
traditionnellement sont les
organisations des partis et un jour ça
lui posera le problème
patrick mennucci on l'a vu à l'ailé
et les écolos tirent leur épingle du jeu
en tout cas de ces municipales déjà au
premier tour le second semble confirmer
cette tendance
l'alliance qui n'a pas été fait avec
martine aubry c'est une première je
crois depuis 1977 et les écolos qui qui
qui font les qui sont faiseur de roi si
je puis m'exprimer ainsi aujourd'hui
pour les socialistes
écoutez la reine la reine martin est
resté sur son trône
et pendant que nous parlions il ya eu ce
changement
et moi je veux le dire je suis très
heureux pour elle très heureux pour ce
qu'elle a fait elle a été assez mal
traités parce que l'ailé parfois les
écologistes exagère un peu et elle avait
mené une politique très écologiste à
lille et on a essayé de la faire passer
pour ce qu'elle n'était pas un bouquin
elle a remis les pendules à l'heure en
quelques minutes et je trouve que c'est
une très bonne chose de sympa de nous
parlons il y a des dizaines de villes
qui sont des de basculer marseille va
certainement de bascule et je peux vous
annoncer que le front national est battu
dans son secteur
que madame galy nationale le
rassemblement national pardonnez-moi est
battu dans ce secteur madame magali et
telus dans le ciel très largement et je
crois pouvoir dire que martine vassal et
battu dans ce secteur c'est pas pour les
autres mais en tout cas manifestement
martine vassal ne sera pas maire de
marseille donc il y a la une
une situation qui est qui est tout à
fait intéressante dans la bo dire ce
sont des municipales il n'y a pas eu
beaucoup de votants mais en fait quand
même tout à l'heure mais poser la
question c'était une sanction pour le
gouvernement
je ne sais pas si c'est une septième au
loup alors m mais ce n'est pas une bonne
chose mais ce que je constate aussi
c'est que les républicains qui ont une
position très ambiguë à l'égard de la
république en marche paye les pots
cassés parce que à bordeaux il y avait
un accord entre la république en marché
et
et les républicains qu'en est-il de
strasbourg on me dit que les choses sont
extrêmement tendues voilà je crois qu'il
y à là ce soir le retour quand même de
la gauche dans le pays
ça se voyait dans le climat qu'on
pouvait avoir mais on voit que les
électeurs ont quand même traduit cela en
faisant confiance à des équipes parfois
dirigé par des écologistes très souvent
dirigées par des socialistes
effectivement il est clair qu'il y a une
importance pour nous aujourd'hui à nous
rassembler le parti socialiste il est
prêt mais nous avons aussi notre
spécificité notre spécificité c'est
notre nature sociale et il faudra
trouver la formule pour aller ensemble
aux prochaines élections en étant partie
aux formes de ces deux orientations qui
doivent maintenant se conforme audit
communiqué quand vous dites que je doit
s'unir ça veut dire également avec la
france en sont ils ont le sait la gauche
n'était pas parti avec monsieur
mélenchon au point mais toujours le même
c'est pas le parti socialiste qui veut
pas s'unir avec lui c'est lui qui a une
détestation expliquez moi pourquoi jean
luc mélenchon mais pas raison de ces
élections municipales pourquoi il n'y a
pas de liste de la france et de son mise
pourquoi les élus de la france est
soumise qui seront élus ce soir sont
cachés dans des listes citoyenne ou je
ne sais quoi
ce n'est pas séduit c'est en tout cas
une façon raisonnable de faire les
choses maintenant si jean luc melenchon
voulait soutenir un candidat et que nous
ayons le même candidat lui les verts et
le parti socialiste je pense comme
terminerai avec l'épisode mâcon et
l'aider est les cartes sont rebattues
selon vous je crois pas je ne sais pas
pourquoi atomisation dans un deuxième
temps de toute façon on a toujours de
liste c'est vrai si c'est ce que veut
dire monsieur benedetti il y avait
beaucoup de triangulaire et de cadres
angulaire de cette élection
mais c'est l'émergence de la république
un marché aussi
la poursuite de fort national mais je
crois qu'il faut essayer d'être simple
on va le 15 mars il y avait des
résultats qui étaient absolument
exceptionnel pour la gauche dans tout le
pays
malheureusement la situation sanitaire
n'a pas permis aux français d'en prendre
conscience et aux commentateurs de faire
les commentaires à ce qu'elle a ce soir
on parle de 13% des municipalités 1 ils
n'ont pas de la franchise ça se voit là
et vous avez tout à fait raison et de le
souligner 13% des municipalités mais
quand même 40 % des habitants des
français là ce soir on a quand même
quelque chose de clair il y a
la perte de 2,2 de lyon il y à la perte
de bordeaux il ya la perte de nancy pour
la droite qui sont quand même des villes
qui fait pour la lra mais pour la droite
qui sont guère des villes qui étaient
des fiefs bouckaert idéologique de cette
ligne là il y a des dizaines de communes
de plus de 10 mille habitants où la
gauche et singulièrement le parti
socialiste passe quand on fera les
comptes
on s'apercevra que le parti socialiste
droit certainement dix fois ce 12 fois
plus de mer que les écologistes ou que
les communistes que le parti socialiste
est en situation de moi ce que je crois
c'est que c'est un signe bien sûr pour
le pays
mais c'est surtout un signe pour les
socialistes qui doute ceux qui pensent
que leur parti est fichue excusez moi du
terme
ceux qui pensent que leur parti ne vaut
plus rien et bien ce soir les électeurs
dans les territoires on dit aux élus
socialistes
vous avez fait un bon travail et vous
qui proposait un programme
je vous soutiennent et vous êtes vous
êtes mon mergen cela devrait être
quelque chose de fondamental dans
l'esprit des dirigeants socialistes pour
se reconstruire en passant bien sûr des
accords avec europe ecologie les verts
et avec les autres forces de gauche
mais le parti socialiste doit reprendre
de la fierté ce soir
c'est ça que je crois qu'il y ait pour
moi ce qui est le plus important de ce
qui se passe dans cette élection